[Music]
well Prince Harry and naked are about to
spend their final weekend as a single
man and a single woman some would say
free man and free woman
Keltie Knight is in London in the middle
of it all with the latest on their royal
wedding and all the preparations what's
going on Kathy hey keV yes that is
Windsor Castle and so essentially we're
in the Queen's backyard right now which
is where we met up with her today we'll
get to that but first we spotted the
Spice Girls out in London which has
reignited speculation that they'll
perform on the big day here at Windsor
Castle et has learned exclusively that
the Spice Girls have been invited to the
royal wedding and will be attending next
weekend our source adds although there
is no plan to have the Spice Girls
perform it is a wedding and who knows
what could spontaneously happen Mel B
was coy when I asked about it last week
Melanie VIII will you be at the wedding
will you perform I'm not sure but look
at this yesterday she joined Geri
Halliwell and Emma button at a swanky
London hotel to catch up of course
Prince Harry goes way back with the
Spice Girls that's 13-year old Harry and
his brother William meeting them at the
London premiere of spice world back in
1997
now with just eight days to go a source
tells ET quote megan has normal last
minute nerves
we're told her mom arrived Wednesday to
help her deal with any pre-wedding
jitters and Megan has crossed one big
item off her to-do list her dress a
source tells ET Megan had her final
dress fitting a week and a half ago
since this is Megan's second wedding her
gown is expected to be an off-white
shade